GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU ALL
FOR COMING TO OUR FINAL HEARING.
I TRULY ENJOYED SERVING AS THE
ACTING CHAIR FOR THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES SUB.
ONE SERVING ALONGSIDE MY
COLLEAGUES HAS TRULY BEEN AN
HONOR AND WE HEARD SUCH
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET REQUESTS I
THANK THE MALL FOR ALL THE INPUT
THEY HAVE PROVIDED WHICH HAS
BEEN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
WE HAVE HEARD A PLETHORA OF
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BUDGET ASKS
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS YEAR.
IN BOTH HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
WE WORK DILIGENTLY TO PROVIDE
YOU THE BEST POSSIBLE BUDGET
WITHIN OUR MEANS.
WHILE IT MAY NOT BE PERFECT AND
IN FACT IT IS NOT PERFECT.
IT MAKES MAJOR STRIDES IN MOVING
US INTO THE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO ENSURING ALL
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE ACCESS TO
THE SERVICES AND CARE THEY NEED.
I'M VERY PROUD OF THE FINAL
PRODUCT WE ARE PUTTING FORWARD.
I WANT TO ESPECIALLY THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR ALL THE WORK
THEY'VE PUT INTO.
HELPING US WITH THIS BUDGET.
I WANT TO THANK THE LA -- FOR
THEIR TREMENDOUS WORK FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE GIVEN THE VERY BEST
INFORMATION AND VERY BEST
ANALYSIS.
I WANT TO THANK THE REPUBLICAN
STUFF CINDY.
HILLARY FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK ON
THE COMMITTEE.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF.
ANDREA MARGOLIS WHO REPRESENTS
US IN HEALTH AND THE COAL
BOSCO'S IN HUMAN SERVICES.
I ALSO WANT TO TAKE THIS MOMENT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
IS BLANCA RUBIO DR JIM WOOD.
MY MY COLLEAGUE ALSO JAMES RAMOS
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE -- MISTER
MATHIS MISTER PATTERSON -- I
WANT TO THANK YOU ON ALSO MISTER
FRAZIER WHO.
IS.
ATTENDING TO ONE OTHER COMMITTEE
BEFORE HE JOINS US.
I ALSO WANT TO TAKE THIS TIME TO
THANK THE CHAIR OF THE SUB ONE
DOCTOR JOAQUIN ARAMBULA WHO HAS
BEEN CHAIR FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING FOR ALL OF HIS WORK.
IN SETTING THINGS UP TO MAKE
THIS A VERY SMOOTH TRANSITION
FOR ME AND FOR THE REST OF US.
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU.
ALSO AND MOST ESPECIALLY I WANT
TO THANK OUR TIRELESS ADVOCATES
WHO HAVE DONE IMPERATIVE WORK.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
WORK ON THESE ISSUES AND FOR YOU
ADVOCACY DURING THIS YEAR AND IN
THE PAST AND I KNOW.
THAT ADVOCACY WILL CONTINUE INTO
THE FUTURE.
NOW WE WANT TO THEN I DO WANT TO
UPDATE YOU ON ONE THING ISSUE
TWENTY SIX AND EARNED PART A
RELATED IT TO RE AUTHORIZING THE
NCO TAX WILL NOT BE ACTED ON AND
SUB ONE TODAY.
THE CHAIR OF THE FULL BUDGET
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO FOR THIS
ISSUE TO BE HANDLED THROUGH
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER. FOUR FOR
PART EIGHTY WE WILL BE GROUPING
THE VOTES [inaudible]
AS FOLLOWS [inaudible]
OUR BEFORE WE START GROUPING WHY
DON'T WE TAKE ROLE.
REYES.
HERE FRAZIER MATHIS YOUR
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS.
RUBIO.
WOULD.
HI ALL RIGHT SO THE FIRST
GROUPING.
WILL BE OF FOR THE FIRST VOTE --
IT'S INCLUDES SUPPORT FROM ALL
MEMBERS.
AND WE WILL COVER THE FOLLOWING
ISSUES. THREE THREE NINE ELEVEN
THROUGH. FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THROUGH.
1-921-322-2420 SEVEN THROUGH.
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN TO
FIFTY TWO FIFTY FOUR THROUGH.
FIFTY SEVEN FIFTY NINE THROUGH
[inaudible] 697-173-37670 EIGHT
THROUGH. 981-003-1231 TWENTY SIX
THROUGH.
ONE FORTY ONE AT ONE FORTY THREE
CAN I PLEASE HAVE EMOTIONS.
THANK YOU PLEASE TAKE ROOM
[inaudible]
REYES.
HI FRAZIER MATHIS [inaudible]
ARSON [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOOD.
THE SECOND VOTE.
INCLUDING SUPPORT FROM JUST THE
DEMOCRAT MEMBERS WILL COVER THE
FOLLOWING ISSUES [inaudible]
ONE
TO TEN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SIX FIFTY
THREE FIFTY EIGHT SEVENTY TWO
ONE FORTY FOUR AND ONE FIFTY CAN
I HAVE A MOTION TO SUPPORT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU PLEASE TAKE ROOM.
REYES I FRAZIER [inaudible]
MATHIS THE PATTERSON
[inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOOD.
AND BOTH OF THESE WILL BE LEFT
OPEN FOR MISTER FRAZIER WILL
READ LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN -- FOR
FOR HIM TO ADD ON NOW WE'LL GO
THROUGH THE REMAINING ISSUES --
ISSUE.
SEVENTY CAN I HEAR MOTION PLEASE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS SECOND PLEASE TAKE
ROLE ON ISSUE NUMBER
[inaudible]
SEVENTY REYES I FRAZIER
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOOD.
ISSUE NUMBER [inaudible]
SEVENTY SEVEN CAN I THE MOTION.
PLEASE TAKE ROLE REYES AYE.
FRAZIER MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOULD.
ISSUE NUMBER NINETY NINE WE GET
A MOTION TO APPROVE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
WE MOTION A SECOND PLEASE TAKE
ROLE IN ISSUE NUMBER.
NINETY NINE REYES I FRAZIER
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOULD.
ON ISSUE ONE TWENTY FOUR GOING
TO GET A MOTION TO APPROVE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE IN ISSUE.
ONE TWENTY FOUR REYES HI FRAZIER
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOULD.
AN ISSUE ONE TWENTY FIVE CAN I
GET A MOTION TO APPROVE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
IF MOTIONS SECONDLY SICK ROLE
RAMOS I FRAZIER MATHIS
[inaudible]
PATTERSON. OH SORRY.
RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOULD.
ON ISSUE ONE FORTY TWO AND I GET
A MOTION TO APPROVE.
STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION AND SECOND.
FEDERAL PLEASE REYES I FRAZIER
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOULD.
AND FINALLY ON ISSUE ONE FORTY
NINE CAN I GET A MOTION TO
APPROVE STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
THE FIRST MOTION A SECOND PLEASE
TAKE ROLE.
REYES I FRAZIER MATHIS
[inaudible]
PATTERSON RAMOS [inaudible]
VIEW [inaudible]
WOOD.
THANK YOU AGAIN THAT.
RECORD WILL BE LEFT OPEN
[inaudible]
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
PART. FOR PART B. [inaudible]
HUMAN SERVICES.
HOUSE BEFORE THE FIRST VOTE WILL
BE FOR ISSUES FOR WHICH ALSO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE SUPPORTING.
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
SECOND WHAT VOTE WILL BE FOR
ISSUES FOR WHICH DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS ARE SUPPORTING THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS ARE NOT.
AND FINALLY AFTER THAT THERE
WILL BE SEVERAL ISSUES TAKEN UP
INDIVIDUALLY.
FIRST VOTE THEN WILL BE TO COVER
THE FOLLOWING ISSUES
[inaudible] 1-339-113-1920. ONE
TWENTY THREE THROUGH.
313-333-9401 THROUGH
[inaudible] 454-074-0850 ONE
THROUGH. SEVENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
NINE THROUGH. EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY
FOUR THROUGH. EIGHTY NINE NINETY
ONE THROUGH. NINETY THREE NINETY
SIX THROUGH. NINETY NINE ONE OH
TWO THROUGH. ONE OH FIVE ONE OH
SEVEN THROUGH.
ONE TEN CAN I GET A MOTION
SUPPORT STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION SECOND.
PLEASE TAKE ROLE REYES HI
FRAZIER.
MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO.
HAS FIVE I'M SORRY I WOULD.
HAS SIX POLITICS.
THANK YOU THE RECORD WILL BE.
ROLE WILL BE LEFT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
SECOND VOTE WILL BE TO COVER THE
FOLLOWING ISSUES. 232-409-7890.
NINETY FIVE ONE HUNDRED AND ONE
OH ONE I HAVE A MOTION TO
SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATIONS.
I HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
PLEASE TAKE ROLE REYES HI
FRAZIER.
MATHIS NO PATTERSON.
RAMOS.
RUBIO.
WOOD [inaudible]
HAS [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
NOW WE WILL TAKE THE INDIVIDUAL.
THE REMAINING ISSUES.
ISSUE NUMBER.
TEN CAN I GET A MOTION TO
APPROVE STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU WITH MOTIONS SECOND
THE SICK ROOM.
REYES HI FRAZIER [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING PATTERSON.
PATTERSON OF VOTING RAMOS.
RUBIO.
WOOD.
HAS.
FOR ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY CAN WE
GET A RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE
STAFF RECOMMENDED MADAM CHAIR
I'D LIKE TO PROPOSE AN
ALTERNATIVE MOTION.
FOR THE PROPOSAL IN ISSUE TWENTY
ON THE AGENDA.
THE MOTION WOULD BE.
THAT WE INCREASE. TO AN 8%
ACROSS THE BOARD RATE.
STARTING IN JULY FIRST.
THE MOTION AND A SECONDPLEASE
TAKE ROLE.
REYES.
REYES NOT VOTING FRAZIER MATHIS
AYE PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS.
RAMOS NOT VOTING RUBIO.
RUBIO NOT VOTING WOULD.
WOULD NOT VOTING HAS.
TO THE MOTION FAILS.
CAN I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF STAFF ON
ISSUE NUMBER.
TWENTY WE'VE MOTION IS SECOND
PLEASE TAKE ROLE REYES HI
FRAZIER MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
HAS.
SIX ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY CAN I
GET A MOTION TO APPROVE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
I'M TWENTY TWO ISSUE
[inaudible]
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU.
WE MOTION A SECOND PLEASE TAKE
WRONG REYES HI FRAZIER MATHIS NO
[inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
NOT VOTING [inaudible]
YES [inaudible] ONE OF PATTERSON
NOT VOTING RAMOS [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
HAS.
FOR ISSUE NUMBER.
FORTY CAN I GET A MOTION TO
APPROVE STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
WE MOTIONS SECOND PLEASE TAKE
ROLE REYES HI FRAZIER MATHIS.
NOT THIS NOT VOTING PATTERSON.
SORRY PATTERSON ABSENT RAMOS.
RUBIO I WOULD [inaudible]
HAS.
FOR ISSUE FORTY SIX CAN I GET A
MOTION TO APPROVE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
WE'VE MOTIONS SECOND.
PLEASE TAKE ROLE REYES HI
FRAZIER MATHIS NO [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
THE RAMOS.
RUBIO HI WOOD.
HAS.
FOR ISSUE FIFTY CAN I GET A
MOTION TO APPROVE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION -- MOTIONS SECOND
PLEASE TAKE ROLL RADIUS HI
FRAZIER MATHIS HI.
PATTERSON.
RAMOS.
RUBIO I WOULD [inaudible]
HAS.
SIX ISSUE EIGHTY THREE CAN I GET
A MOTION TO APPROVE.
STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION A SECOND PLEASE TAKE
ROLE REYES HI FRAZIER MATHIS
[inaudible]
PATTERSON.
RAMOS.
RUBIO [inaudible]
WOOD [inaudible]
HAS.
SIX ISSUE NINETY FOUR GOING TO
GET A RECORD THAT CAN I GET A
MOTION TO APPROVE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION.
ISSUE.
NINETY FOUR THE MOTION IS SECOND%
PLEASE TAKE ROLE REYES HI
FRAZIER MATHIS NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
PATTERSON.
RAMOS RUBIO.
WOOD.
HAS.
FOR FINALLY ON ISSUED ONE OH SIX
CAN I GET A MOTION TO APPROVE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
WITH THE MOTION IS SECOND PLEASE
TAKE ROLE REYES HI.
FRAZIER MATHIS [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAMOS.
RUBIO I WOULD [inaudible]
HAS [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
I KNOW WE GAVE LOTS OF NUMBERS
VERY QUICKLY ALL OF THESE WILL
BE POSTED.
SHORTLY ON THE WEBSITE FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
I DO WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
ONE PERSON I FAIL TO RECOGNIZE
EARLIER AND THAT IS FROM MY
STAFF AMR RASHEED. FOR ALL OF
HIS TIRELESS WORK.
WITH THE COMMITTEE.
WITH THE REST OF US THANK YOU SO
MUCH AMOR.
A LITTLE BIT.
ROLL WILL REMAIN OPEN THAT.
CONCLUDES THE BUSINESS BUT THE
ROLE WILL REMAIN OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS I ONCE AGAIN I THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE AND FOR
PROVIDING ALL OF YOUR INPUT.
IN ASSISTING US TO GET TO THE
DECISIONS MADE HERE TODAY THANK
YOU
CALLING ABSENT MEMBERS.
IN PART A HEALTH.
FIRST VOTE COVERS ISSUES. THREE
THREE NINE ELEVEN THROUGH.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THROUGH
1-921-322-2420 SEVEN THROUGH.
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN THROUGH.
FIFTY TWO FIFTY FOUR THROUGH
FIFTY SEVEN FIFTY NINE THROUGH.
697-173-37670 EIGHT THREE
SEVENTEEN I'M SORRY 782-981-0031.
231-263-1401 AND ONE FORTY THREE
PLEASE CHECK CALL THE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
FRAZIER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
SECOND VOTE.
ISSUES. ONE TO TEN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SIX
FIFTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO ONE FORTY FOUR ONE FIFTY
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
FRAZIER HI.
ISSUE SEVENTEEN CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
FRAZIER.
HI.
ISSUE SEVENTY SEVEN CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS FRAZIER [inaudible]
HI.
ISSUE NINETY NINE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
FRAZIER HI.
ISSUE ONE TWENTY FOUR CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
HI.
ISSUE ONE TWENTY FIVE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS FRAZIER.
ISSUE ONE FORTY TO CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
FRAZIER HI.
ISSUE ONE FORTY NINE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS FRAZIER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
PART B..
HUMAN SERVICES.
FIRST VOTE WILL COVER ONE ISSUES.
1-339-113-1920. 1-233-313-3330
NINE FORTY ONE THROUGH
454-074-0850 ONE THROUGH.
SEVENTY SEVEN SEVENTY NINE
THROUGH. EIGHTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR
THROUGH. EIGHTY NINE NINETY ONE
THROUGH. NINETY THREE NINETY SIX
THROUGH NINETY NINE ONE OH TWO
THROUGH ONE OH FIVE ONE OH SEVEN
THROUGH.
ONE TEN PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS FRAZIER.
HI [inaudible]
HAS.
SEVEN SECOND VOTE WILL COVER THE
FOLLOWING ISSUES.
ISSUE. 232-409-7890 NINETY FIVE
ONE HUNDRED ONE A ONE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS.
FRAZIER HI.
HAS [inaudible]
FIVE HE DID.
ISSUE TEN CALL ABSENT MEMBERS
MISTER FRAZIER [inaudible]
HAS.
FIVE ISSUE TWENTY CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER FRAZIER
[inaudible]
HI.
FRAZIER I HAS.
SEVEN ISSUE TWENTY TO CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS.
FRAZIER HI.
FRAZIER AYE HAS.
FIVE ISSUE FORTY CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS FRAZIER [inaudible]
HI.
FRAZIER AYE HAS.
FIVE ISSUE FORTY SIX CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER FRAZIER.
HI HAS.
FIVE ISSUE FIFTY CALL ABSENT
SEVEN ISSUE EIGHTY THREE CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS FRAZIER HI HAS.
SEVEN ISSUE NINETY FOUR CALL
ABSENT MEMBERS FRAZIER.
AYE.
FRAZIER AYE HAS.
FIVE AND THE LAST ISSUE ONE OH
SIX CALL ABSENT MEMBERS FRAZIER.
HAS.
FIVE THANK YOU THIS CONCLUDES.
OUR HEARING FOR TODAY